actor and comedian Cedric the
Entertainer he has been called comedy's
renaissance man and he has starred in
dozens of films and TV shows including
the Steve Harvey Show the original Kings
of Comedy and of course the barbershop
franchise Cedric the Entertainer
currently plays Calvin Butler on the hit
CBS comedy series the neighborhood it's
about a white family from the Midwest
adjusting to their new life after moving
to a predominantly black neighborhood in
Los Angeles now in this clip Calvin
struggles to find the perfect gift for
his wife Tina take a look
this year is going to be different
I got her the most amazing gift a
genuine Chanel jacket straight off the
runways of Paris
look like it came straight from the
Guangdong Province
yes you're gonna love it baby here we go
oh yes oh no
hey man that's too small
I could see that Dave yeah so I don't
have to point out that it's spelled
Channel
and no well looks like your street
continues
all right that clip is from the 100th
episode of the neighborhood it also
features cameos from oh there's some
notable people there oh my co-host on
the talk first on CBS Morning Cedric the
Entertainer joins us now welcome good
morning good morning how's everybody how
you doing it's good um we're doing great
now that you're here I mean this of
course marks such a huge milestone a
hundred episodes for the neighborhood
why do you think this show resonates so
much with viewers no I think you know
the show came on at the right time you
know we had a lot of you know racial
discourse going on in the country and
this show just kind of talks about like
what it is to be neighbors to be big
neighbors with someone that you not like
not actually like them in any kind of
way and you feel like really different
and then how do you build that
relationship over time and I think by us
getting to 100 episodes it just really
shows how uh it does take time to build
to that and I was really glad for the
show that we didn't have to rush the
idea like we're over the seasons we were
you know I I became a little friendlier
with Dave and a little more allowing it
in the same for him you know so by the
time you get to the fifth season we're
friends and you know yeah exactly yeah
looking out for each other you're not
only the executive producer of this show
you also directed this episode which we
at the top got to see you directing all
of us which was amazing how do you do
that I'm so kind would I not
get over there sit down by the way I was
just an extra Cheryl Underwood is the
real yes she's the big star and Jerry
yeah they did their thing yeah you were
great oh thank you yeah you could say
what you said I was actually yeah
that's what I said yo but you know
what's very important that one it was
such a milestone to be able to do to get
200 episodes I directed an episode in
season four and so I thought it would
just be important for me to be also
because I've been with the show from the
very beginning and it's experience it uh
to direct this 100th episode so it was
great that came up even came up with the
idea to have you guys be a part of it
because I wanted to do something that
kind of you know what's first everybody
what's the key to being a good director
to getting people to perform their best
I mean the main thing is really is to
watch performers and see what they kind
of naturally want to do with the role
and then and then you know give them
places to you know hit their comedy be
great listen to them and then you know
be able to say all right cool this is
what you do naturally here this is where
I would guide you to make sure that that
lands on TV so that's it this show is
unique for many reasons because it's not
afraid to tackle some real issues you
know gentrification race relations
addiction why is it important to hold up
that mirror and basically show a
reflection of society you know in giving
that to the people to the viewers you
know I think you know we do situational
comedy you get you you're really you're
you're a guest in people's home every
week they allow you to come in and uh
you know it's important that you have so
many you know uh great television shows
nowadays with all the streamers and
everything yeah you know you want to you
want to get a little bit of Slice of
Life out of these situations you want to
have an understanding of what people go
through we play a regular family in a
Suburban part of Los Angeles you know uh
that has this kind of gentrification
issue and and I know that people deal
with that all the time and not only that
is you know we we dealt with uh you know
what they call geriatric pregnancy like
late Life Pregnancy of course of this
season we know with all the road wage
stuff was coming up so a lot of things
that we try to just try to talk about in
a situational comedy kind of way but you
know let's talk about what's going on in
the world you know what I what I love
also about this show is that how it
portrays you as a family not just as a
neighborhood but your own family as the
black father that you are a new her
father in real life how have you learned
from Calvin Butler oh man I don't I
don't know Calvin is rough
he is super happy baby I got a real wife
be like what I was like huh
I feel that yeah you know what I'm
saying but uh you know actually though
it is it is that idea of being uh you
know one that is a protector one that is
a leader in you know and learning to
listen but probably the greatest lesson
I learned is that on the show I have
adult kids and and so you have to
recognize that you have to listen to
them as well as you trying to guide them
and none of my kids have kind of grown
from high school and into college area
you recognize it's time for me to also
listen to them and not think that but
just because I'm the dad I can just tell
you everything because yeah you can
learn a lot by listening to your kids
and seeing what they want oh you sure do
real quick though are you gonna hit the
stage anytime soon because you're one of
the greatest comedians oh yeah man I'm
performing I'm going to do it right now
man okay so uh straight jokes No Chasers
BDL Julie earthquake okay
we'll be out here in New York yeah we're
gonna be in uh Barclay on the 22
episode of the neighborhood this Monday
at 8 7 Central right here on CBS and on
Paramount Plus